You know what they say about people with big
feet… they’ve got biggggg brains.
Because they’re human.
Because humans have big brains.
That’s what this episode is about.
Perverts.
Hey there brainy buddies, Jules here for Dnews!
If you compare the brain of a human to that
of a chimp, one of our closest genetic relatives,
you’d see a pretty notable difference.
The human brain is three times larger than
the chimp’s.
By bodyweight, humans pretty much have some
of the biggest brains, pound for pound.
To be fair, the award for largest brain in
comparison to weight goes to the ant, whose
brain makes up about 15% of its mass.
But having a larger brain doesn’t necessarily
make a human or animal smarter.
Researchers have long discounted the theory
that human brains are so big solely because
we’re so smart.
We have a video about that, so check it out.
I know I’ve met people who are dumber than
my fish Lenny, despite the brain differential.
What’s more, having a big brain may seem
to be a disadvantage, at first glance.
Although in humans, the brains make up 2%
of our mass, they use a whopping 20% of our
blood and oxygen.
That’s more than twice the amount compared
to other primates.
That’s pretty interesting, because besides
having much larger brains, humans are also
much weaker.
An according to at least one study, those
two things may be related.
The study in Brain Behavior and Evolution
suggests humans developed larger brains at
the expense of muscle mass: they call it the
"energy trade-off hypothesis."
Researchers looked at changes in genes that
transport glucose, an important energy source,
and found that in comparison to chimps, orangutans,
and macaques, human genes tend to emphasize
providing energy to the brain over the muscles.
But that still doesn’t explain why we evolved
bigger brains to begin with.
The answer to that might have the most to
do… with our homies.
Yup, friendships, social relationships, and
other complex interactions may just hold the
key to our big-old brains.
It’s known as the “social brain hypothesis”,
and it suggests that non-neural intensive
tasks, like sleeping, eating, or breathing,
are not really related to brain size.
Even problem solving is not wholly responsible
for an increase.
But thinking about people -- keeping track
of who is doing what to whom and why and how
we fit into those relationships -- that takes
a ridiculous amount of processing power.
And guess what, for humans, being good at
interpersonal relationships is one of the
best ways to get someone interested in you
and eventually propagate the continued existence
of the species.
That’s right -- sex.
And in fact, this social brain hypothesis
kind of makes sense.
In an analytical study of skull fossils, researchers
from the University of Missouri compared a
huge number of potential brain-size factors,
including climate levels, the number of parasites
around, population density and more, and they
found a strong correlation for that last factor.
The more densely compact a population, the
more likely they’d have bigger brains.
So, in the end…
maybe our evolution is based on social prowess
over having big muscles.
Which is a pretty nice thing to hear when
you’re a funny guy who only weighs a buck
fifty.
Ladies, get at me.
I got it where it counts.
Our brains have been through a lot of changes.
Even texting changes our brain.
And I’ll let Trace tell
you about that in this video.
What would you rather have - big muscles or
a big brain?
Let us know…